well here we go she is an author a
speaker an entrepreneur and a Las Vegas
local making a big difference in the
lives of women and men too Across the
Nation well joining us now is gallite
Ventura Rosen to talk about empowering
women and some actionable tips that we
can all take and I I think we're going
to feel motivated by the time we're done
with this interview it's so nice to meet
you galit I should get you out of your
seats and get you dancing that's what I
do at my speaking engagements oh my
goodness well the female Tony Robbins
inspiration and and we love it obviously
local but you know here we are in a
national women's History Month
International women's day yesterday and
we do want to focus on women because a
lot of times we're still trying to push
through that glass ceiling and find what
makes us happy yes yeah and you've got
your successful businesswoman but really
you said through later years you
discovered what really speaks to you and
you're passionate about how do you
Empower women and motivate us all my
favorite thing in the world is to show
women how to believe in themselves
because we're not very good at that
we're just not good we'll tell our son
our sister our mom our dad our best
friend how amazing they are but we never
really say I'm amazing and I think
that's the first thing that I love more
than anything is look you're amazing no
matter who you are no matter what you do
no matter what you've done or what
you've gone through today you need to
remember that you're amazing we forget
that a lot don't we it's it's easy but
you hit the nail on the head it's so
easy to inspire others around you but
you forget about yourself and I think
women just have a tendency to be more
competitive but there's a better word
and a better way for women to work
together right I I love the word
collaborate collaborate I believe
there's enough success in this world for
everybody and we have this mindset
sometimes where we don't think there is
oh they're successful there's no way I
can be but when women start
collaborating working together
supporting each other I mean sky's the
limit for success and we should
celebrate that too we should celebrate
other people's successes and not be
jealous and it's so petty you know
because you can learn from each other
and you need to celebrate what one
person has and maybe you don't but you
offer something very different another
Talent there is so much to learn from
other women so part of that though the
key would be what listening yes so we
want to celebrate our successes we're
not good if that is women but we also
want to recognize that sometimes we just
need a good year we don't need to be
judged we don't need your opinion we
don't want to be told what we should or
shouldn't do listen and then ask
are you do you just want me to listen
are you asking me to give you advice and
give you my opinion because as women we
love to do that we really do
it's true though how did you get so
successful though and become such a
powerful motivational speaker and
because you're all over the world you're
everywhere now my answer is very simple
I am a hundred percent myself every
single day good bad and ugly I don't do
Perfection I don't do everything is
perfect all the time I share my failures
my successes my challenges my good days
and my bad days so other women can
relate to me because sometimes they look
at us they say oh they're on TV they're
perfect no we don't wake up this way we
know better we it takes a lot of work it
took a lot of work to get to who you are
to be comfortable and confident in your
skin she's got an incredible book that
kind of talks about and solidifies all
that and I've been talking about it all
morning because you have almost like a
million followers on Instagram and I
love following you because you have such
great advice it's not just you know sexy
photos you have some substance to offer
right successful woman mindset all right
so or so nice to meet you thank you so
much and where can people find you uh
Delete venturerozan.com okay all right
thank you so much all right coming up
we've got plenty more after the break so
please stay with us